this opportunity to present yeah I hope
to advertise a tool for the construction
of finite models finite structures that
is very aware of symmetries that are
involved in such tasks or can be
involved in such tasks given the time
constraints this can only be hopefully
and an appetizer for you to look at the
the actual construction that is rather
technical but I already talked about
some features some applications some
strands in this in other and other
occasions in this wonderful Science
Institute program so it's thanks for all
these opportunities and now just a short
summary of some of the ideas that's I
hope some of you will find interesting
and that may be looking for many more
applications so what I mean by
amalgamation well it's a basic task of
Sofia foutch using together two pieces
in a single amalgamation step and I'm
looking at some extended processes of
amalgamation here where you want to
continue fusing more and more pieces
according to some pattern and this has
to do with issues involved in local
versus global consistency but also local
versus global symmetry and in some of
these areas you're really looking for
patterns that can be used in order to
generate nice and symmetry preserving
solutions to such tasks so this occurs
in many areas I would say now just of
trying to give a very rough idea of
where it could occur i mean synthesis
navigation tasks occur in hypergraphs
and relational structures in all kinds
of decomposition or composition tasks in
model theory you have homogeneity
aspects that have to do with an argument
as many of you may know in geometry and
combinatorial geometry you may think
also classical or differential geometry
you may think of Atlas is in charge
where where these fusion is really to
glue together and bring together these
local views in order to give a picture
of the overall object the entire
manifold say local and partial
symmetries occur of course in logic
model theory are very much a partial
isomorphisms our local symmetries
partial symmetries and then some
you can extend them to global symmetries
algebraically are this certain fields
with group Boyd's or equivalently
inverse mi groups much more than with
the sort of perfect symmetry behavior
that is reflected in a group then local
consistency of course occurs in many
places ranging from databases constraint
satisfaction to possibly quantum
information issues and I hope to well
convinced you that there is an
underlying task that occurs has some
impact on many of these areas and so
think of a construction task like this
the specification that you have is a
family of relational structures and a
family of pairings between them that are
partial pairings that tell you how a
certain structure of type a s say wants
to be identified partially according to
some row e with a region in some
structure of type a s prime for some
other s prime so at the purely
combinatorial level you would really
have a diagram that says which kind of
kinds of structures you have this is the
index s and s prime of 2 such
contributing structures in the family
and you have links between them directed
two links here edges in a multi graph
that would say identify some piece of
structure a s with a certain piece of a
copy of structure s Prime and keep doing
that but so of course for a problem like
this there is a canonical generic free
realization that just serve users
basically all possible walks that you
can have in this abstract representation
of the gluing pattern that we want to
realize and and put a copy of the
corresponding structure in the right
place so whenever you arrive on a walk
at s at little s then you put a copy of
fresh copy of structure a s and
identified with the place where you
previously were along this walk
according to the corresponding row e
that got you there right so this I want
you to note pictorially semi pictorially
by this notation here you take something
like a free product and factor out with
respect to the identifications that are
in
used by the edges in those walks that's
so this realizes in the terminology that
I want to suggest here this overlap
pattern that's given in the
specification or Marga mation pattern it
is free in a universal algebraic sense
because you've basically not identified
anything that happy not have to be
identified according to this
specification it's generic but it's
obviously always infinite unless your
pattern happens to be finite and
everything is fairly trivial anyway okay
so the question that I'm treating here
is what are the finite analogues obvious
other find out solutions and if so how
do you get them based on what kind of
background structure instead of this
usually infinite ma nguoi dove all walks
through the all combinatorial
representation of the links that you
need to realize could you have anything
that's equally homogeneous as this of
canonical one and can't control cycles
or these the behavior with respect to
cycles that occur and make the whole
thing interesting and potentially
problematic with respect to global
consistency issues of course in the
asari in the in the in the free
realization you don't create any cycles
right but if you want to keep it finite
and eventually you'd have to fold back
onto yourself and their cycles and then
you need to discuss how about them how
to which extent can you avoid them to
which extent can you avoid at least
dangerous ones that would lead to
inconsistencies let's say just for
technical purposes here's a very rough
idea of what the actual definition of a
realization in the general case is that
we want to apply to the task of finding
finite realizations then so the overall
structure that we want to construct
should consist of lots of patches of
these types that are given in the
specification so you can think of an
atlas really in these of geometric sense
but you have passions that declare
themselves as being isomorphic copies of
a s for various of these kinds of
structures ASDF you have in such a way
that locally if you have two pieces that
we clear themselves as copies of a s one
piece that it declares itself to be a
copy of a s
then for every one of those gluing
actions that were provided or required
in this specification you really find
something that overlaps with that piece
there in exactly the right way and the
way in the sense of how its declare to
be a copy of a s Prime and so you just
have really have all the extensions all
the gluing operations in place where
they were specified this is the obvious
part of the definition this is the
non-obvious part which sort of tries to
keep this safe and sane namely whenever
you have overlaps in this server a class
of pieces that declare themselves as
copies of AAS and a DSA then the actual
overlap in the resulting realization has
to be forced by some composition of
gluing operations that were really
required so there is no incidental
overlap that would just of have firm
well have occurred because you put glue
in places where it wasn't necessary to
put you that's so the second no nonsense
condition is something that goes in the
direction of keeping this as free as
possible and also to avoid potential
relational inconsistencies and this is
an aspect of global consistency that
we're discussing here because
compositions of partial isomorphism not
totally safe nothing can ever ever
happen with respect to use of
inconsistencies incurred by just of
stacking one composing one part lies in
motion we have another partial as
emotionally the third one but if you
look at unions of partial eyes them all
for them so if you can get to the same
place along different routes then this
is dangerous because the union of
partial isomorphisms typically isn't one
right and that's where inconsistency
globally inconsistency can rise even
though locally the partial I some
awesome tell you everything is
consistent so are just um because we're
going to use group Boyd's and you could
go to use inverse inverse Mr groups as
the kind of backbones finite backbones
that we place the monoid of all walks
which is infinite in our constructions
our composition structure of partial by
Jackson can be described algebraically
or combinatorially either with a partial
position operation in which case you get
to inverse semi groups or which is a
total operation though all you use exact
composition where you only compose them
where they match in terms of domains and
ranges and then you're talking about
groupoid which have a partial operation
of composition because it can only link
them where they match okay so goo Boyd's
but you could have used in verse mi
groups just instead server in for
partial symmetries or partial by actions
what groups do for global by directions
global series that's sort of a bit of a
background why these structures arise so
in the context that we're talking about
here I want to use blue points that are
somehow designed to match the underlying
combinatorial pattern of sites that you
want to link and the way in which they
are linked by identifications that are
in the specification that I called I
lessor sub i's and I just put this year
because I didn't see it on this side the
I was the structure consisting of the
sorts of structures that we want to put
and then edges in a multigraph sense
that link some of these sites according
to two labeled edges and the labels
tells you tell you which identifications
you dokely want to before so here I use
a group-wide whose elements G is the set
of all driven elements come in different
sorts namely group group odd elements
that take you from sword s to sort tea
would be one such sort of good water
element and then you have an associative
composition operation but you can only
link things that match together in the
sense that here are elements that take
you to tea here are elements that take
you from tea and then you can combine
them to get an element that takes you
over all from s to you in this case you
have neutral elements in versus sits
like a group but with a partial
composition operation that respects
sorts in the sense of taking you from
here to there to there in this picture
of sites and links between number and we
have designated generators here for for
this notion of group work that matters
such as
they are labeled by the edges that you
have here and of course respect that the
time later this is the potentially
finite analog of the infinite paths
monoid that was used in the overall very
generic but infinite solutions that are
talked about first but and indeed the
kinds of perform an actual product with
this kind of group would right way but
you you use the group of elements as
addresses for copies of structures of
type asos prime to make them according
to this if the address that you have
here gets a modified to become the atoms
g times e for generator e then you link
these two copies according to the row
either I told you how to do copies of
this kind but question is when is this a
realization in the sense of this
definition that our heart and obviously
it always gets the first condition right
you always blew everything in in places
where it needs to be dude but how could
you maybe run into difficulties with
respect to global consistency issues and
have more identifications then are
allowed according to this second no
nonsense of freeness condition there are
two kinds of abstractions that they come
from cycles in this group Boyd structure
that gives you the addresses of copies
of structures that you want to put and
one is a simple one namely you could
have parallel identification
requirements that come from some
composition of actually necessary local
identifications along a path w one in
the group or part of generators you can
think path w two they could link the
same two types of structures with these
same addresses s and T but maybe they
don't match right so you could even have
here in the in the in the overlaps of a
clear mismatch because only individually
do you know this is a the two individual
regions are objectively mapped to the
union of the two you needn't even be by
section
so this is actually the easy one they
did more difficult one is the one that
really deals with potential violations
of global consistency that come from the
relational content in their structures
so here the domains and ranges of the
corresponding identification paths are
disjoint so that happens nothing in
terms of spoiling consistency with
respect to elements but you could spoil
things with respect to consistency for
relations linking these elements because
even though this is a partial
isomorphism and that one is a partial
item also their union need not be if for
instance you have an error or red arrow
notice of their red its relation going
upwards here and downwards there but the
only way to consistently realize then
these requirements would be too well at
least introduce two more copies and
unfold this twist so as in if you've
played around with this maybe with it as
in a mobius strip sort of situation
where you have one twist which of forces
you do to bring things together in the
wrong direction but if you do the whole
thing twice if you unfold this cycle
once as it were and do a double covering
then it all fits nicely right then this
kind of cycle needs to be treated this
would be a bad cycle if the red edges
are present in those structures asn 80
and we need to avoid these bad cycles
and the question is what what what sort
criterion of a success it is you in the
right one and it turns out that it's not
generator cycles as you usually consider
when you look at Keighley groups for
instance and just have one to forbid
certain short cycles formed by
generators its cycles that are formed
being formed by cosets and I'm briefly
trying to explain why these cosets cases
like this matter first of all what is a
coset cycle here you go from one you
can't as one step a transition lot
within a certain subset of generators
takes you from G to some g prime so this
could be a long sequence of actual
generators so we're not controlling the
length of that at all it's just a
certain kind of generators that take you
there by however long a composition you
like so why is this
why does this address the kind of danger
that I have pointed out with this mobius
strip kind of twist situation but think
of this situation again this is in the
in terms of the desired imagination
product that we produce with addresses G
& G H 4 copies of a s and on a tee and
we have one identification part this way
in the after part for the bluish pieces
or bluish elements a1 and b1 and another
one along some completely different
paths of generators w2 that takes a two
to be two button now you could have sort
of mismatched edges between these a 1 a2
and b1 b2 as in the previous sketch now
if you look at the same situation in the
report that gives rise to these
addresses g and h g times h well then
you can think of the generators in this
bluish region here those are the ones
that take a one and maintain it as you
compose these generators so those are
the ones that stabilize or carry a 1
whereas the pinkish ones are there is
that carry a 2 button you see that here
we are going along completely different
connections of generators namely those
that carry a 1 and there's that carry a
2 and come to the same destination and
this is exactly the kind of problem
areas are be slightly enlarged same
picture as just now so think of the
bluish part as consisting of being a
coset here in this space of addresses in
the group void being a cow set that is
generated by all those generators that
carry the element a1 through all their
compositions and similarly for the
pinkish set down here what we want is
that we can also go from this address g
to the address GH using a composition of
generators that carry both a1 and a2 so
you would like that this h can also be
represented as a sequence of generators
as a composition of a sequence of
generators that carry both elements
simultaneously because then you
you don't have this problem then being a
composition of partial isomorphisms they
would carry an arrow from a1 to a2 say
into an arrow from b1 to b2 right so
what we want is no hurry here like what
this condition here says is really just
that you could also go in the
intersection of these two generator sets
and arrive in the same destination no no
this is just avoiding a certain to cycle
formed by code sets and this is why i
posted a cichlid a CSU matters and for
the rest of this talk I just have to to
give you a quick run through of the
results that can't be obtained in this
direction in terms of existence of such
nice nicely behaved finite group voids
and uses well there we brief glimpse of
different users that have already been
made of this that first of all you can
in a combinatorial and rather
non-trivial construction produce reports
that are as good as you like in this
sense namely for any flesh out for the
length of cosset cycles that you want to
avoid capital n there and for any
underlying pattern of sorts and links as
in the overlap specification there are
finite group points of this type that do
avoid all cosset cycles of length up to
em but in particular you can get rid of
two cycles of cosets and thereby
overcome any difficulties with respect
to global inconsistencies in these very
doing processes the idea well maybe I
shouldn't go into this but this is a
rather complicated into leaving of
combinatorial group actions on certain
partial amalgams of subgroups or katie
graphs of subgroups etc and you have to
work rather hard to get this so this is
where the papers long are the corollary
we get really that this proposal to put
such amalgamation constructions on a
background structure that is a
well-behaved a nice group for this kind
but this always works and you can
actually achieve realizations in the
wave that I've advertised that respect
all the symmetries of the input
structure so that we don't break that
make any arbitrary choices anywhere in
the construction that the fattest of a
nice feature generosity and that you
have any desired degree of local ASIC
lyssa T in terms of overlapping copies
or the structures that you glued
together but so locally in terms of just
not too large portions of your final
result you will not see any cycles if
you don't like them and and you have
local tree decomposed ability in terms
of the patches that were glued together
let's so in this sense it's generic and
at least locally free of course it can't
be totally free because that necessarily
makes it infinite if you started from it
from a cyclic pattern initially some
applications are the first one is really
one way don't even start from a southern
arbitrary overlap specification of the
kind that I outlined in the beginning
but you start from a realization of a
novela pattern may be an actual hyper
graph if you have a finite hyper graph
may be stemming from a relational
structure would have you then you can
with this construction abstracted
overlap pattern and then produce
realizations of the same open a pattern
that avoid all cycles of hydrangeas up
to a certain length so these are a
cyclic sensor acylic na cyclic
hypergraph coverings that you obtain in
a finite manner and it's this kind of
hyper graph coverings that actually play
a great role in these characterization
results where you want to play games
because label you can make things a
cyclic for say the analysis of the
finite model theory of guarded fragments
and I think like that where the hyper
edges are the guarded patches that need
to fit together in a nice way but
shouldn't form short cycles that would
be detectable in a hitter have first
order Android price a game say
okay another one which I mean that
thing's actually what them brought me to
this whole brought me to this problem of
producing amalgams of the right ASIC
icity behavior the other things that are
mentioning here especially came out as
well as a surprise that you can actually
deal with bother interesting results on
the extension of local to global
symmetries using exactly those same nice
crew point constructions so this EP PA
stands for extension property for
partial automorphisms and problems may
be best explained in terms of this
sketch you're given a finite relational
structure a together with some
collection and here i put a single
internal partial isomorphism or this
structure and the task is to find an
extension which is still finite
structure be so that the original a sits
as an induced sub structure and in such
a way that this local symmetry that you
have inside a extends to global symmetry
of be right now what does that have to
do with overlap realizations of the way
that i talked about so far well
obviously if you think of extending this
partial isomorphism that you have
internally to a that means it carries a
whole copy of a that's fixed to this
part to that thing here yeah get another
copy of a so you keep adding copies of a
that need to overlap according to the
behavior of the partial isomorphisms
that you want to realize and turned into
global symmetries and so here we obtain
actually as a corollary of the
construction that i sketched for any
finite structure a and any collection of
partial I top bottom orphans on that
structure an extension that is really
just obtained from gluing pieces or
copies of a according to the
identifications that are necessitated by
the partial isomorphisms to give them
partial isomorphisms and make this so
symmetric as to really solve this epp
a question and also to make it as a
cyclic a cyclic in terms of the pattern
that the overlapping copies of a make
out in this overall in the structure be
as you like so you cannot make things
such that the access of a charts that
you just get by the automorphic images
of the copies of the original structure
a four-man na cyclic hyper graph in the
sense that small size n sub graphs sub
hypergraphs are actually a sick dick
tree decomposable nicely behaved and
therefore the construction is locally
free and universal if you look at any
small pieces then it's really pre like
the realization that you get and
therefore remains universal with respect
to homomorphisms and this is interesting
because the strongest of the results
that you have up here is one that is a
conditional statement and it works
within a class of structures with some
set of forbidden homomorphisms so you
forbid certain configurations in the
target structures and of course in the
given input structure a and then this
statement has to be turned in to find
out model probably that says if you have
any solution in such extension that
extends the given partial symmetry is to
global autumn or fizzles of a structure
that doesn't realize they're forbidden
configurations then you have a finite
solution of this kind this is what comes
out here just because locally and in
terms of some finite controlled areas
you are as generic and as free as the
free construction which would be
infinite anyway and so we get the full
strength of this finite model theory
finite model property version this
conditional statement on extension
properties for partial isomorphisms from
the nice well-behaved nature of the
realizations but come out from this
group or construction what and then this
has various uses in modal and guided
logic self which were already briefly
referred to an eris talk this morning
find out model properties and find out
controllability questions for guarded
logics
and some of their relatives can be
treated if you subject the corresponding
models or plans for building models to
this kind of generic realization that
avoids short cycles but because cycles
apart from multiplicities are the big
things that you can't control with
guarded assertions or say couple
generating dependencies and things like
that and therefore you need to smooth
things out with respect to short cycles
you want to avoid them and to boost
multiplicities which is always easy in
this way this is a major tool in
characterization theorems that work both
classically and in the sense of finite
model theory for the garden fragment and
some of its extensions relatives that
have recently been studied including the
guarded negation of fragment after Eric
mentioned which is wealthy so the
biggest nicely behaved fragments of
first-order logic in this family that we
now have and I want to say that that's
been covered in some sense but here
another class of characterization
theorems that work for moda logics
extended by non-first order constructors
like common knowledge operator where you
have a fixed point like construction in
the background which is clearly seems to
be long in the remit of monadic
second-order logic but in a civ tame
fragment of that of course and it turns
out that it can use these kaylee groups
in this case even groups not you don't
have to go to reports for that
application and use the structural
analysis that's being suggested by the
way that these models are generated
systematically from a set of generators
and of controlled cosas de sagacity in
order to play and fish fry say games on
here in in a domain that's that's a
challenge because it really goes beyond
first or logic and a little bit in the
direction of melodic second order on you
okay so i think i should stop here but
here are some related references that
range from applications to the garden
fragment on for instance the guarded
negation fragment to nice discussion of
the concept of guarded by simulation in
an earlier paper with eric a very odd
thing on conformal hypergraph covers but
didn't mention explicitly but so
basically the work that i'm talking here
about a badge here now it includes the
results that we obtained there which
could only deal with one aspect of a
sickly city and hypergraphs and now is
the limitations have been overcome then
this surly glasgow theorem that i
mentioned this EP be a result that can
be reproduced here and the technical
source fall of this is the last one
which is on archive but the better
version is the more current version on
my homepage questions
well I'll ask all is good quick question
something that if you if you wanted to
apply this to for devil to UM to get
fine eight models of it for the
extension axioms for four graphs you
know the random graph theory like what
would it could it possibly help you to
do this oh it's an interesting
suggestion I've not thought about I mean
this is part of the hope that but all of
you have nice ideas where else this
could be applied because it really has
turned out to be a tool laughter that
seems to solve many more tasks than the
one it was designed for but but I've not
looked into into that specifically and
to me though though using it to to
characterize or in a bit hey no no I
mean of course you you you you see you
have to have you have to have an
environment although the problem needs
to arise in a situation where you don't
worry about producing more copies of
things right so way you can't count in
some sense it don't have control of
multiplicities in fact it's a way to
overcome the inability to deal with
multiplicities to determine them
therefore you need to make them large so
that large enough is indistinguishable
again all right so in some sense it's
going in the opposite direction I mean
it doesn't help to analyze concrete
structures because here you want to use
an incredible freedom of unfolding
things locally to do it to any degree
you like but keep it finite so find out
is the only thing that I can guarantee
sizes for instance are awful in all of
this right i mean these these very
generic group words that i obtain their
must necessarily be incredibly large and
i would blow up anything that would come
into its of a reasonable complexity
consideration let me see where i'm
coming from anyway give you look at your
spelling muscle but i wanted to describe
the sort of generic you give me a
structure i want to describe the generic
search in some format things affect you
and then maybe there's some some
description of it that you can take in
and compute on that rather than on your
it's it's so somehow you're building a
canonical estimate of the original
mm-hmm possibly yes I mean of course
similar amalgamation things occur a lot
when you go to fry say limits etc what
one could ask in which situations do you
actually realize some of the properties
of the limit in sufficiently large
finite approximations but that's
something that I happen to explore
either ladies were clearly my servants
program and by the finite fondue furios
in extension expert primary graphs by me
my problem the wonderful distances
actually cuz i asked the same problem
for the fighting bottle property crabs
with distance operators and there's no
no known construction of that in any way
and so you're doing this you might even
have a experimental way to try to get
you know possibly finite models of a
very simple kind of of those axioms
that's that's really intelligent test
because you mentioned that of a security
criteria be it's open as far as i know
in a very interesting open problem that
i would have hoped to solve with this
but so far then see how to do this heavy
glass car type of extension property for
say for cycle-free graphs for three
cycle-free we can do it here but because
three cycles i click i mean they're
they're not really cycles and four four
four cycle free shopping if security
case they are finite mother's property
rights yeah well i'm not i'm talking
about this extension property for
partial isomorphisms or whoops what does
this has been we deactivated for I know
I either switched off maybe
inadvertently I mean in in in this sense
here the conditional statement that if
you have a solution that is for
cycle-free very infinite then you will
have a four cycle free finite solution
final solution for the extension tasks
not and this is not not a model of any
obvious theory that you would put with
them
a combinatorial task which is kind of
find out model property if this how much
fat is in your construction and I'm
sorry fat fat so you say sizes are awful
yeah but it was too quickly to
understand but it looks like they have
to be yeah actually we're looking into
this I mean I don't have any really good
lower bounds but the construction of
course is such that the group odds that
I produced here hours of off-the-shelf
solvers for any such problem right so of
course in many cases you really want to
look at seiko set cycles that are formed
by very specific kinds of code sets not
arbitrary combinations of generators but
the constructions that I have would
really solve any such problem equally
well and that equally a tremendous cost
in one go right so you don't actually
look into the actual say topology of the
structures at hand or the the way in
which they need to be linked it's just
stuff in terms of numbers of generators
and and how many different sites you
labels you haven't and I mean up up to
that it's it's sort of generic also in
terms of the machinery that I'm using
thanks very much